hey everybody welcome to a gamespot
plays of blood-borne I'm Eric T and I'm
lucky to be joined by a giant bombs Brad
shoemaker hello all right doing alright
how about yourself not pretty good all
right let's do this yeah blood born in
my possession so known okay so you're
you're in this like starting area as
well I know yes oh I'm up to the second
boss now which is a little bit past this
but okay I came in here and so please
don't spoil things so here we are I know
you're way past me though have you been
playing this game like around the clock
since you got it yeah pretty much I mean
so this is my first kind of like for a
in the I wouldn't call this a Souls game
because it's not obviously but you know
I would okay there now this game is
basically Dark Souls 3 and all but name
okay i guess it's so similar at the top
level at least but they've changed so
many little specifics underneath to know
yeah but but i won't get ahead of you no
worries how are you finding us before um
like the highs are high and the lows are
low for young I sounds about right yeah
i mean i get really frustrated at things
and it's hard for me because i haven't
come from the souls background obviously
and it's funny just having all these
people surrounding my desk watching me
because they're like oh my god it's
blood-borne and then they're like oh
you're kind of being greedy man you're
being greedy I'm like what do you mean
I'm being greedy and they're like you
shouldn't attack as many times and kind
of trial by fire I've learned just to
kind of like just from dying so many
times you just kind of learned that you
got to kind of slow it down yeah these
games teach their harsh lessons pretty
quickly for sure are you just gonna wait
in there that the weird thing is like
they don't all aggro right like I feel
like so just so you know like the
further you go I feel like they're aggro
range gets a lot bigger um I was using
like pebbles and what not to draw their
a go initially it's kind of like the hey
I'm over here you know I'm gonna try to
do the visceral ah I didn't work okay so
firearms yeah I know this is your first
one of these so you may not be super
aware of the firearms are like a big new
thing here okay they've never done guns
before like I've had you know they've
had projectile attacks you had magic of
various types and the other games but
guns seem like they serve a very
different
roll here have you really figured him
out yet like I'm still trying to grasp
the nuances of what they do they're like
what the role is yeah but for those so
what I'm being told actually is after
some people watch me again it's kind of
like it acts like the repost okay I'm
Dark Souls so like if I time this right
hopefully and then well it didn't work
that time but if you time your your
gunshot properly you can stagger okay
your enemy and then if you are one right
away which is like you're quick melee
attack you can finish them okay so it's
kind of like a backstab to in a way back
yeah it's like a fun time are you yeah
it's like this wrong with that yeah yeah
so I knew the guns were supposed to be
used as an interrupt of some sort but I
didn't okay that's good to know I'm sure
exactly like we're in the kind of attack
chain they came into play yes I wasn't
using them as much at first until i
finally saw like one of those notes
that's like oh hey you should totally
you know try to time your your gun shot
and then they'll get staggered Oh God
let's not die here and that's another
new thing it didn't really show their
let me try to get more life here but uh
like getting hit and then you can
lifesteal back now yes which is the
other one for something new yep
absolutely but I also find it like it's
like a tea / it's very tempting they'll
be like oh I could just life steal it
back right and then you kind of start
mashing your attack and then all the
sudden is like oh god yeah I'm getting
hit especially come from the old games
when you hear about that it's like oh if
you just hit them right after you get
hit you'll get the life back like it
sounds like this huge like convenience
feature but yeah it actually just needs
to a bunch of really terrible decision
making yeah I've caught myself many
times like oh yeah just lifesteal right
back all right I'm totally fine i'm at
seventy-five percent health and then you
just drop them you have taken more hits
when you go in there and try to get the
health back yeah yeah everything about
the changes they made of the combat in
this seem like they're focused on making
you get in there and just fight more you
know like they took shields out you know
they're basically no way to block
anymore the the dodge like the role
isn't has turned in like a Dodge you
know when you're locked on you know more
of a sidestep than a roll so is that so
is that the same in dark clothes no no
no the side step is totally new like if
you just could lock onto one of these
guys yeah I'm gonna go right now yeah so
you've got your you've got your standard
role that was in all the games but then
yeah as soon as you walk on
yeah it's like that very quick dodge as
you know like sword and shield was like
a very valid and popular play style in
the old games and there aren't as
shields and like I said the dodging is a
lot quicker also there's guys with guns
shooting at you yeah they like a really
long range of if you saying how far they
can kind of like a gross so like in
general the changes the combat here seen
a lot more focused on making you be
nimble and avoid things and fight
quickly rather than you know like a lot
of people would just kind of turtle with
their shield and big sword mm-hmm in the
previous games and that's another thing
to like the health vials you can get up
to 20 now which kind of is is very
different from you like like I said I
haven't played darts holes but I've
watched enough dark souls to be like
okay you have like 4 s this fuss or like
five you know and like you have to be
really careful with how you use those
but I found that in the beginning of
this game I don't know if it's just
because it's the beginning and they're
kind of trying to train you a little bit
but I got 20 potions like really quick
yeah you can have 20 at a time and yeah
you like so many enemies drop them all
the time that you're kind of max for a
long time also it seems like the surplus
ones you pick up actually go back to
your storage yeah they go to a stash you
go back and pick up but yeah they also
show up like if you don't have 20 let's
say and you die with 16 but you have
surplus it all just I think it'll start
with 28 but you do hit a capacity yeah
but that yeah you're right they don't
they don't just come back for free like
they did in Dark Souls yeah but you know
in Dark Souls every time you went to a
bonfire you've got all your Estus flasks
back hmm and that's another thing there
is no bonfires anymore there oh yeah so
there are their lamps yeah and they
don't really function the same way I
easier to talk about it when we get to
one yeah I've actually i'm actually not
thrilled with some of the changes they
made to the way the bonfire / lamps work
oh you guys like pain in the ass
sometimes like I still have engaged like
I fought these guys a bunch but
sometimes I can't gauge like distance
you're like what they're gonna do cuz
it's not always oh here's a that's it
that's the back step oh go there so if
you tell me that right they have to be
kind of staggered to them right so the
arts you like this move well that's what
staggers them but you have to make sure
you're behind them okay and then if you
do the floor too it'll stagger them and
then you can just finish them off
how much have you played around with the
transforming weapons because that also
seems like a big new addition yeah like
for me I've never personally like two
handed weapons on any game because it
just feels really slow but you can
actually combo into the yes just figure
that out really which is amazing like
that like yeah typically like if you
just hit they'll one right now you can
kind of show people what happens
basically you can turn your weapon from
like a you know it's kind of faster
lower damage to a slower higher damage
type thing yep give you more range
because it is the devil right hand
obviously but I was going in every
battle going like all right I either
need to be like short along here oh and
just pick one but yeah like you said I
just figured out that yeah you can kind
of mid combo yeah transform into the
other version and kind of keep it going
we'll say I'm still kind of getting used
to like the camera angle stuff yeah the
camera like this it's still an issue in
this game I've definitely had my deaf
swear like the camera kind of went
behind a wall yeah if you're on a corner
an edge or something it's absolutely
possible to totally lose track of what's
going on and then die which is pretty
much dark souls I almost had it so
that's how you would use the gun is if
you can time it right you can you can
stagger them the same way I did with the
back side and you'll if you're close
enough and you don't get hit you'll do
that same kind of like one hit animation
I swear oh okay oh that's weird I
thought it opened that door already so
the guns are effectively kind of like a
like an active defense item then I guess
if it makes sense yeah I posted like a
shield where you're just holding a
shield at the block mm-hmm because the
shields were however you did the kind of
a repost okay like kind of counter
attack stuff and the previous games yeah
the interesting thing though is like so
I know in Dark Souls there were classes
whereas in this game it's not really
classes it's like here you have an
origin of like your backstory of who you
are and like this positions in this
instance i picked like the violent past
or something so my strength is like
really high or higher than the other
ones right but in terms of like the gun
mechanics the gun gameplay you can
actually like if you actually expect in
the blood blood tinge I
you might be able to play a ranged type
character with a gun but I haven't seen
anything like really special guns yet in
the game so what do you have for guns
only got the pistol that I started with
um so I picked the blender bus instead
because it's it as an AoE it's like kind
of like a shotgun effect on the only
other ones I've seen is like a repeating
pistol that shoots two bullets but it
obviously uses your quick silver bullets
more um yeah which are pretty limited
you can look at 20 of those a time to
then you're picking them up everywhere
so it's kind of a huge deal yeah Jesus
you can also use a torch though I other
secondary I almost feel like this is you
want to whip it out here yeah what I do
like the others I almost feel like
that's a response to like hold i'll cry
about Dark Souls to wait and the kind of
dynamic lighting stuff that they pull
out of the game they promised and then
didn't deliver at the same time like I
don't feel like there's you know so the
trade-off here is like you put the torch
in your off hand instead of your gun and
then you know you don't have a gun you
can shoot but I don't feel like there
are very many situations where you
really need the torch to see what's
going on mm-hmm like even a default
brightness like even even in the darker
areas i can still pretty much see well
enough to not use a torch like it almost
seems like more of a cosmetic thing uh I
will say there's benefit later okay
alright i don't know i won't say why
let's go to sara lee but um I the torch
actually you get a better torch later on
okay does a little bit more damage which
is the one I have now huh so I've never
really actually attacked with the torch
as it is it like a decent Oh what is it
it's okay it actually gets a boosted
with your arcane damage so we end up
specking ARCA is not a lot it's not a
big amount but it does affect it let me
see if I can get this guy with a torch
enough i've been picking up an items
like an oil urn or something that you
can throw on guys too yeah we'll try
that I'm that would boost the damage too
oh yeah I would assume that that would
you know cause it to be way more
also like the scaling of my damage here
is probably like higher so don't think
that the torch is gonna do 135 damage
your buddy's convoy higher than my main
hand weapon is cool right uh that's not
good yeah so I learned that that was the
thing to the one of the ways I died in
the very beginning was that I was like
oh yeah I'm fighting this guy up top
it's going to be all good and then he
kind like punted me off the platform
like oh that's that's kind of the thing
about the big movements that you take in
these games as you attack and stuff like
that you know like you kind of can't
always predict where you're going to end
up yeah so let's go down here there's
some some dudes kind of chilling in the
water but I mean I'm liking it i would
say for anyone that is thinking about it
and hasn't played a Dark Souls game you
kind of have to just have a lot of
mental fortitude yeah and a lot of
patience yeah I'll definitely say if you
have played these games and didn't like
them like there's nothing here for you
like they have not addressed any of the
things that would have put you off about
the previous ones but if you did like
them like it's kind of everything that
was there and works I feel like I don't
know what it is about this version that
made me kind of want to play the game
versus like Dark Souls games because I
never really wanted to play at dark
souls games before that was my mind like
it feels like thanks for like tailor
made for you I'm like you're like you're
no stranger to hard games that require a
lot of like kind of technical
proficiency you know yeah wait there's a
lot of been maxing that goes on in the
games with the stat builds and like you
know weapon attack patterns and all that
stuff like you know if you like to get
inside a really technically complex game
and really break it open like these
games are totally for you yeah I mean I
think part of the reason why I didn't
like what I saw from dark souls at the
time and maybe it was not a good enough
perspective was that I saw a lot of like
blocking and it looked kind of slow and
clunky and this was supposed to be that
kind of response to speeding things up
and you definitely do feel that at first
like like you said earlier if the game
is kind of pushing you to attack more be
more aggressive you know like you lost
some life it's okay if you time it right
you'll get your life back but again it's
like the caveat is you have to be
careful because if you're too aggressive
you
get punished for it right especially
against one of those stronger monsters
that do a lot of damage well talking
about sword and boarding your way
through dark souls like it's kind of
been like a running joke among like
Souls connoisseurs or whatever like that
that's like the most boring kind of easy
mode way to play mmm so kind of feel
like this game is confirmation that the
developers also feel that way because I
took that out you know like that was the
like you said that was a slow safe way
to play through those games yeah so
clearly the philosophy here is like hey
that's not going to cut it anymore what
if I told you there could be a shield
though I may have seen a shot of that
shield floating around if it's the one
that I think you're talking about have
you read the tooltip what it's made of
wood have you read the tooltip on that
thing I don't know maybe we should read
it today I should look at the tooltip on
that thing if you want to know what the
developers think about she pulls all
right you want to do it let's rock it
out oh you've got so much more stuff
than me don't just don't look the crude
wooden shield used by the masses who
have arisen to join the hunt hunters do
not normally employ shields ineffectual
against the strength of these as they
tend to be shields are nice but not if
they engender peseta so that's like
that's just like straight up taking a
shot at the people who hung back with
shields catch and the old games like
they're basically saying like a [ __ ] you
yeah anyway right yeah I used it and it
was kind of like very jank and it didn't
really block anything at all yeah
totally literally they want you dodging
and you know interrupting with the
firearm and stuff have you done anything
with this guy this guy oxide died oh I
can totally feel with this guy I could
deal with this guy you want to see let's
let's show him first or he's gonna he's
gonna go crazy and then and then we'll
show you some dark souls as cheese
tactics to this guy let's do some sort
of get out right like that's another
thing I learned using corn or is like
pulling them back as far as possible
shame whatsoever and using all the tools
at your disposal so there's a couple
ways you could deal with him oh god yeah
I got him yet yeah he can straight-up
kill you on the ladder
man it's Pumbaa happy man all right so
there's two ways to go about it the
first way I actually when he came out
like that and I just straight-up dodged
I took damage but what I did is I ran
past him because you need to get into
that room because there's there's some
items you can get from the roof let me
show you how to get there before we we
end here this is also a good spot yeah
we'll show you something some potential
Indiana Jones old souls fans will
definitely appreciate this for sure I
got lucky I be honest like the first
time I oh no oh my god away is it not
trigger a little trick oh oh rock it up
oh sure so that was cool right yes I
think so I I was i thought it was being
smart right I was like oh dude that
fired that huge ball of fire that
dropped down that must be what you use
to kill the pig right and then I was
like so i lured him out and then all of
a sudden i go there and then he's not
dead I'm like oh he went back inside
damn it so it turns out you can either
go past them and run past them or there
is another area you can get to mucca
which is here on this side let me try to
speed through this here we will use a
accident maybe we'll just uh just skip
by this guy was just skipped by them
there's a ladder here oh crap yeah
always that's another thing I forgotten
to go down this ladder cuz there's
something else right after this that I'm
hell-bent on beating right now ya know
England by yes so I've been ignoring
this funny thinkin so you can know you
can hold circle to slidell rudder oh
yeah thank you oh my god thank you so
much holy crap I didn't enjoy this life
changing moment yeah also you can also
hold circle to climb ladders faster
really yep okay that's gonna let change
my life because somebody was saying that
to you when they were watching me that I
can't you hold X or something like I
don't think so so basically you could
eventually get his snout stuck there yep
this is the time-honored tradition they
showed right over he just kind of light
up kind of whale on him and he's just
like oh I can't do anything nice I was
okay but the sad part for me is he just
dropped smiles that's just what he does
like there's a lot of these side bosses
I guess
it's more for the area so there's stuff
in here you want to get but yeah there's
a lot of this kind of stuff like like
many kind of glitchy things that you can
do I actually glitched father gag aureus
who really are I probably butchered his
name yet but uh yeah he was in a tree
and then he just disappeared it would oh
that would be so noise yeah that's who
I'm still going right but uh without
spoiling anymore that's kind of like a
just a little light bite of blood-borne
it's kind of a run in the mill yeah you
know like you said if you're in the dark
souls you're probably totally going to
me and I'm sure that's all my all my
friends are saying that I would say if
you're not and you're thinking about it
I picked it up I haven't played it I'm
enjoying it and no I'm not just doing it
because of work I actually was like oh
blood-borne might be the one for me and
I don't like 20 to 30 hours already yeah
it's I mean it's super grueling but it's
also like you said super rewarding once
you're kind oh yeah get over those huge
fist pumping with no bosses and I and
everyone behind so yeah good job like
yeah so I think so much bad for joining
me on the couch today oh thanks for
having me yeah so stay tuned to
hopefully next week ish will maybe have
a review up if not maybe a review in
progress we'll have to see kevin van
noord is suffering suffering right now
yeah thanks guys
you